[Music]
what's today's date yeah
what year Paul Walker who died in a car
crash in Santa Clarita California in
2013 is being remembered in a new
documentary titled I am Paul Walker I
can actually say he did a lot of things
that made a lot of difference in a lot
of people's lives you know she was a
giver in the film's first trailer
friends family members and colleagues
paid tribute to Walker who was 40 years
old at the time of his death he'd always
say like I wanted to be a park ranger
you know make 28 grand a year and like
live in the wilderness that's really
what he wanted to do the preview also
includes home videos of Walker riding a
bike and hanging out with his siblings
he liked to go fast
thankee soon as I was old enough to hang
on tight I was on the track of his big
lo if I'm going for the ride of my life
rob cohen who directed 2001's fast in
the Furious and walkers manager Matt
Luber echo those sentiments cinema
didn't capture it all couldn't capture
it all Paul was always an actor who had
one foot in and one foot out he just
disappeared but the most tear-jerking
moment involves his Fast & Furious
co-star Tyrese Gibson if you loved him
the way we did you would say well why
him and not us
[Applause]